all right now this is a story you
haven't heard much about but I'm gonna
ask a question on ya think about it
is China hindering free speech on
American soil how can that be
well Wang Dan who's a former leader of
the 1989 Tiananmen Square protests and
founder of an independent think-tank
that promotes democratic reforms in
China says the Chinese Communist Party
is extending its surveillance of critics
abroad reaching into Western academic
communities and silencing visiting
Chinese students here through a campaign
of fear and intimidation Beijing is
hindering free speech speech in the
United States and in other Western
countries on college campuses we have
enough problem with free speech college
campuses now we got it from China
joining us now for analysis from Florida
Stephen Mosher a China expert and author
of bully of Asia and here with me in
Washington Sher Khan Ali Khan who's a
graduate student at Catholic University
and a spokesperson for persecuted
Chinese civil rights activist Gwen Gwen
Chung let's start with you Steve you've
been covering China for years I know
none of this is surprising to you I
think a lot of Americans however are
shocked to know that Red China and yes I
still call them that Red China has such
a long arm into the u.s. academic
community tell us how they're
intimidating speech on campus
well lurid has a long arm into the u.s.
academic community the arm is getting
longer all the time I'm kind of the
poster child for the persecution and by
China of American academics and and
American students who criticize the
Chinese regime for human rights you
recall we've talked before about my
reporting on forced abortions in China
which led the Chinese government to
demand of Stanford demand not ask that I
be expelled from the University and
Stanford complied that was a long time
ago China is larger and more powerful
today than it was then
it was much more active in suppressing
speech yeah they're more money they have
a lot they have a lot more money and
sure comes specifically what's happening
on the college campuses so college
students most of them come for
the the white-collar class in China and
most of those people are employed by the
Chinese state state-owned enterprises
and those students feel pressure when
they're here in the states to
self-censor
they know that their social media is
monitored and that has a very strong
chilling effect so I was looking at a
chart
I think the Wall Street Journal did it
of the number of Chinese students in
2000 come to the United States and 2000
verses today and I believe the number
today was a over 500,000 in the United
States that sound right to you I think
yeah well I've seen at least over the
chart goes like this yes on the right
thank you yes
so there we go so it's on there that's
what we where we are essentially today
at top yeah a lot of Chinese students
here more surveillance for social media
more pressure on the upper class
specially Chinese to abide by the
Communist dictates now does this happen
in in pressure on their families at home
does this happen in in subsidies being
removed educational subsidies he said
how does it spill over into the other
parts of campus yeah well it's a it's a
very sophisticated strategy where they
they monitor social media and they know
that they have you know they up the
pressure where the students know that
they might get a call from their parents
saying someone from the government came
to visit us or their parents might be
employed by a bank which is also owned
by the government or if if they really
step out of line the government would
actually imprison their family or I mean
this is Steve and I gotta go back to you
on this this is shocking to most people
because we are a free country we hear
about Russia collusion Russia's attempt
to you know suppose a collusion with
Trump which is ridiculous and the
attempt to influence our election sure
they probably did but what about this
this is China's attempt through setting
up all these Confucian Institute's
Chinese studies at universities some of
them are cool I imagine but boy they
they they have an enormous amount of
power and money operating right now in
the United States for a purpose they
have a purpose what's behind that
purpose well behind that
purposes the idea of controlling all
discussion all debate about China and
they've set up hundreds and hundreds of
Confucian Institute's around the country
they go to a college or university offer
them millions of dollars in return for
room on campus so the Institute's are on
campus they're named of course after
Confucius and not say Chairman Mao
Zedong who is one of the great mass
murders of human history
having murdered 65 million people but
there are certain things that are not
not allowed to be talked about at the
Confucian Institute's you can't talk
about the three T's they're called
you can't talk about Taiwan you can't
talk about Tibet you can't talk about
ten-ton men you guys you can't talk
about Taiwan because wants to be free
they shut it down they do the same thing
in Hollywood there's no certain movies
aren't gonna be made Google Facebook all
shut out we're gonna do a lot more on
this thank you both for joining us